more than 100 million Americans from
Texas to New England are waking up to
dangerous ice and bitter cold today snow
and slick conditions have made roads and
the runways hazardous states of
emergency are in effect in parts of the
south schools are closed in more than
ten states including Texas and Georgia
the huge storm system barreling east
Trez stretches all the way from the Gulf
Coast to Maine
parts of New England could get slammed
with up to eight inches of snow this
time-lapse video shows how temperature
swings above and below freezing created
an ice jam on the Connecticut River
DeMarco Morgan is on the river's edge
and haddem Connecticut DeMarco good
morning good morning to you as you can
see behind me here at the Connecticut
River right here it's filled with huge
chunks of ice and as it ice dam breaks
the water pushes through flooding nearby
homes and neighborhoods just to win will
it break
no one knows frigid temperatures have
made the Connecticut River look more
like a glacier than a body of water and
Kent Connecticut and ice jam forced
evacuations and road closures the Kent
School sent more than 500 students home
after the campus flooded and water froze
in place a six mile ice jam along the
Misses koi river in Vermont turns nearby
streets into a frozen swamp after I mean
ice was building right up it was really
scary slick roads and sub-freezing
windchills in the South are creating
dangerous stretches of black ice
Houston's mayor says the conditions are
only getting worse I am asking people
please stay off the roads please stay
off the roads major roads were littered
with spit out sand pileups officials
shut down long stretches of highways to
minimize accidents from Texas to
Louisiana even emergency personnel found
icy roads a struggle watch out in
Kentucky traffic was backed up for miles
after two tractor trailers and a
Greyhound bus collided at least 11
people were injured
the roads are deteriorating all over the
county really dangerous icy spots all
over the highway as the temperatures
continue to drop the roads will get icer
and more dangerous as for the ice jams
back here the Connecticut River help is
on the way the Coast Guard is coming
through to help break up that ice but
the temperatures are expected to climb
causing more flooding soon back to you
know incredible pictures there DeMarco
thank you so much